it was only a matter of time donald
trump is now claiming that brian kemp's
massive victory over david perdue
remember david perdue is the guy trump
endorsed in the georgia republican
gubernatorial primary of recent of last
week
trump is claiming that kemp's victory
over purdue
was fraudulent newsweek article explains
trump pushes claim that brian kemp's
50-point victory was fraud
former president donald trump save
america political action committee on
tuesday sent an email to subscribers
that linked to an article that claims
governor brian kemp's victory in last
week's republican gubernatorial primary
was the result of voter fraud
no credible evidence has been presented
of widespread fraud in the may 24
primary
kemp the incumbent scored a lopsided win
in the primary with approximately 74
percent of the vote according to the
associated press his vote total was more
than 50 percentage points higher than
the count for david perdue the former
republican senator who was endorsed by
trump
kemp was once a political ally of
trump's
but the former president has since
publicly bashed him multiple times after
the governor refused to contest the 2020
presidential election results in georgia
where trump has falsely claimed there
was voter fraud
uh this
shouldn't come as a surprise to anyone
and i'm going to tell you why
first real quick i want to tell you
about our sponsor aura
one of the fastest growing crimes in the
u.s is identity theft and there's a new
victim every 14 seconds
this has happened to me before i've
talked on the show we got hacked it was
costly it wasn't a good feeling and
that's why i now protect myself with
aura one of our sponsors protecting your
accounts and devices gets complicated
because you need a bunch of different
tools and aura combines them all into
one app identity theft protection
fraud monitoring password management
antivirus all in one place they monitor
email addresses passwords social
security number bank accounts credit
cards if something happens you get an
immediate alert on your phone and then
aura can help me fix it as well aura is
letting my audience try it free for two
weeks at aura.com
pacman with the free trial you can do
things like see if your login
credentials have been found on the dark
web i saw an old password was in four
different data breaches
probably something you want to know and
it's free so you might as well just use
the link down below
all right so it should come as no
surprise to anyone
that the new strategy is if we lost it
must have been fraud donald trump loves
to tout his stupid endorsement record
now i don't know whether he's now
claiming he's 81-2
or 105-3 or whatever the big picture on
trump's endorsement record going back to
2018
is that he's somewhere around 65 percent
now
at its core we should be saying well
that's not that much better than
flipping a coin right if you flip a coin
you would expect to get roughly 50
percent of the winners right in
head-to-head races trump's slightly
better than flipping a coin dating all
the way back to 2018 but understand that
he mostly endorses incumbents or obvious
leaders
it's not because of the power of
incumbency and because of how obvious it
often is who's going to win a 65
endorsement accuracy record is not
particularly good but the story here is
it was known for a while that brian kemp
was going to crush david perdue trump
was behind the purdue train for a while
going all the way back to the special
elections on january 5th 2021
it was obvious purdue was going to lose
and it was written on the wall that
trump was going to say well it was only
because of this or that or the other
thing
and or claim fraud and now he's doing it
perdue got crushed
uh brian kemp won easily 50 points and
they do this it's sort of like a no true
scotsman fallacy of sorts
well everybody i uh endorse wins oh
someone didn't well they didn't really
lose it must have been fraud and by that
definition of course
you never lose
i don't know whether anybody still
believes this stuff i know that when
trump goes to the rallies and he says we
really won this state and we really won
that state or would i i know people clap
but we also know from polling that the
share of even republicans that believe
trump actually won the 2020 election is
declining declining declining my concern
is less about
what do they truly believe because at
the end of the day whether these are
literal beliefs or false beliefs as
we've talked about using cult
terminology what matters is the impact
that it has on the electorate are you
more or less likely to go out and vote
for republicans in november
if you believe there is widespread fraud
and that your vote might not even matter
it stands to reason that if you think
your vote makes no difference you might
actually stay home and that's my concern
and that's my question to you
if voters do believe
trump's voter fraud lies
are they more likely to vote in november
or less let me know what you think in
the comments